I'm gonna bring up H21 and uh
>> just let you guys know a little little
background on H21. He's a young Muslim.
He's been coming to the streams like
consistently and uh he he he can have an
honest conversation as well. So, I
really like him. Last time we spoke, we
were talking about the moral issues
within Islam and uh he was saddened by
it, you know. So, um this is where we
at. So, uh he likes talking about the
the Islamic dilemma, too. So, here he is
on stage. What's up, H21?
>> Hello.
>> Good to have you here, man.
>> What's going on?
>> Well, uh, this this topic, I really like
it a lot and I think I can
>> Someone's phone is ringing. I can't hear
anything. That's H1.
>> Yeah, I think his phone may have just
went.
>> It happens, guys. Don't condemn me.
>> Sometimes Sometimes your real calls,
man. That's what That's what happens.
>> Yeah, I hate that.
>> Got a phone dilemma. Does he answer?
Does he not?
>> Hey, Sean, you there? You kind of mut?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I'm there. I'm just checking
if someone called me. All right. Um, now
I like this uh topic and I think I can
try to debunk it and um I hope you guys
can give me the chance.
>> So every you you knew my uh my way of
trying to debunk it. You know it. So
>> I want everyone to hear it. So let's go
to uh surah 14:4. Allah says all
prophets have their own language.
Jesus's language was Aramaic according
to historians and sources. Surah 5:47.
Allah says all prophets Allah says to
the people of the gospel to judge by
what he revealed to Jesus. Surah 2:79
and surah 3:78 Allah Allah says that
people alter the book and surah 5:48
Allah says that
>> yeah hey dude dude dude dude dude dude
you're you're not going to you're not
going to start off well if you're
already lying. Put put read read 378 for
us. Look I'm not even trying to be I was
I was I was willing to listen but you
just said 378 says they alter the book.
378 says they distort the book with
their tongue. You can't leave that out.
It already sounds like you're lying. It
already sounds like you're trying to
deceive people. So, you got to fix
things like that. Um that might that
might work on that might work with
people who haven't read these passages
before, but um all not this my first
time I recall hearing from you, but this
is not a good start, man.
>> Uh sorry.
>> Okay.
>> I actually thought that's altering the
book, but uh sorry about that.
>> No problem. No problem. Okay. No
problem. Go ahead.
>> So, uh this is my way of um debunking.
So I want to hear your response on how
you can debunk my way of uh debunking
the Islamic dilemma.
>> Okay.
>> So so far I don't think you've actually
given a a finished argument because the
whole point of you saying that it was
altered we already showed you doesn't
say it's it's been changed textually.
Rather they just uh distorted the this
the actual revelation. You see there's a
difference there and you you need to say
well okay here's a verse from the Quran
that says the injur has been corrupted
or here's a verse from the Quran that
says the Torah has been corrupted. You
need to show something like that if you
want to run that argument.
>> Well, uh, the angil and the Torah is not
been fully corrupted nor it's been fully
preserved.
>> Can I ask you like just a real quick
question and I think because this for me
highlights things very quickly. Is there
a single verse in the Quran that says
the injur has been corrupted?
>> No. Unequivocally, no.
>> No. There is no verse in the Quran that
says the injur has been corrupted at all
in any sense. The best you can do is you
can say that people distort its meaning
and they they they hide words and they
try and conceal things. There is nothing
at all that says the angel is not
present with them. In fact, there are
six verses at a minimum. They use the
Arabic word madic in reference to the
fact that what they have with them is
the scriptures. They they have the
scriptures with them. And that's
encompassing both the injur
depending on which verse you look at.
>> All right. So again, you need to be able
to demonstrate some kind of Quranic
verse or verses preferably that show
some kind of actual corruption because I
can show you tons of verses where either
they're confirmed because there's 18
Madic verses where 18 times the previous
scriptures are confirmed by a range of
different people. So that includes
Allah, it includes Jesus or Issa, it
includes uh the jin, Muslim jin actually
say it's confirmed and it includes
Muhammad himself saying it. Allah tells
Muhammad to say that he's confirming the
previous scriptures. That's 18 different
verses at a minimum. Like that's that's
the very base level. We have a lot more
coming. You need to give some kind of
verses that say no no no actually the
Quran is very clear. These aren't like
surah 3 ayat 7 verses. You know there's
clear verses in the Quran, unclear
verses in the Quran. No, no. Here are
some clear verses in the Quran that say
the previous scriptures have been
corrupted. You need to show us that, my
friend.
>> I cannot uh there's no verse that says
that's fully corrupted. And Not not even
saying fully corrupted. I'm saying that
what they have is corrupted that in such
a way that it's not reliable. You cannot
use it as scripture. It is no longer
revelation from Allah. Show me a single
verse that implies that or says it
explicitly either way.
>> All right. I hope this is not
dishonesty. Surah 2 verse 79. People
>> okay.
>> So So you're going with in my opinion
this is the only possible verse you
could possibly bring. This is the only
one that even talks about writing in
this context. The problem I had with 279
is is tons of problems and you're going
to have people from all sorts of uh
different perspectives on this panel
going into this because there's a lot to
cover. The first is I have no confidence
actually. The first is that this is not
talking about the inel for one thing. At
best and at absolute best this is
talking to the children of Israel in the
context
>> and it's talking about the Torah at
best. I don't think it's talking about
the Torah. I think it's talking about a
different book that they wrote with
their hands.
>> Yeah.
>> I think Yeah. Go ahead. Quick, Chris,
just to add and then I want you to
finish what you were saying, but just to
add in like even if the the
interpretation is right that the Jews
corrupted their scriptures, the
Christians we know at the time had their
own Torah and their own scriptures as
well, which we could call the Inil with
them as well. So if anything, we should
be able to compare from history. There
should be different, but we don't
actually find that. We find that
Christians and the Jews had the same
Torah. But continue, Chris,
>> that's a huge point in of itself. The
fact that corruption uh on such a scale
on an interfaith level worldwide between
all Christendom and all of the Jewish
diaspora is is insane. It's it's a
conspiracy theory. Like you if you
believe this, I would ask you to give me
an account of how this is even possible.
I don't think you or any Islamic scholar
ever could. So that's one thing. But I
would actually go farther further and I
would say the next verse, verse 80,
actually tells you what these people
inserted into this book they wrote. And
they inserted something that is not
found in the Torah today. So in other
words, you have two options. either
Allah is wrong when he said in 79 that
they wrote this book and then in verse
80 they are saying this and then quotes
what they say about hellfire being only
a short period of time for the Jews when
that's not something we find in the
Torah it's not something we find in the
Dead Sea Scrolls it's not something we
find in our manuscript tradition rather
it's found in the Talmud and the Mishna
so either Allah was confused with what
the Torah was and accidentally thinks
it's the Talmud and the Mishna or it's
just wrong like Allah thinks this is in
the Torah and he's he's just making an
error And this this is like two basic
criticisms of this. There are there are
so many things wrong. How about the fact
that um six verses later Allah actually
reprimands the Jews at the time of
Muhammad and again your taps the mu they
agree with this interpretation. It is
the mainstream interpretation of verse
five that the there are Jewish tribes in
Muhammad's time that are not following
the Torah. They are only following parts
of it. And he reprehands them for what?
for only following a part of it. And
what does that mean? It means they will
be sent to hellfire. Jews in Muhammad's
time, if they don't follow the Torah and
only follow a part of it, are sent to
hellfire. That's six verses after verse
79 in that same chapter. I I mean, my
friend, I could keep going on. Uh verse
121 says that there are Jews who have
the true recital of their scripture at
the time of Muhammad. How is this
possible? Surah 891
says madun in the context of the Torah
being present with the children of
Israel at the time of Muhammad and the
Quran confirms it. I mean surah like a
verse 89 even says to these children of
Israel how dare you acknowledge that
this Quran it is similar to what you
have and yet you still reject the Quran.
Why would why would the author of the
Quran be saying, "Yeah, the Quran is
like the Torah that you have in your
possession if the Torah in your
possession contains anti-Islamic
man-made corruptions." Does any of this
make sense? None of this makes sense to
me. I I'm following the plain readings
of the text. I'm following the Quran
holistically on all the different verses
that talk about our previous scriptures.
And the Quran is a love note to the
previous scriptures. The Quran loves the
previous scriptures. It has nothing
negative to say about them at all. It
has a lot to say about Christians and
Jews and what they say, but it has
nothing to say about the the actual
scriptures themselves because the QR
confirms them. And the Quran uses those
scriptures as an argument for proving
the validity of the Quran itself and as
and of Muhammad as a messenger. It's a
central argument in the Quran, my
friend. I'll let you speak now cuz I've
been speaking for a while.
>> No, you No, I didn't really understand
what's your main question because my I
was basically almost uh No, I'm not
going to disrespect you or anything. But
I just couldn't really uh follow up what
you were meaning. But I want to ask a
quick question. Where does in the surah
does Allah say um that he will promise
to preserve the gospel and the Torah?
Just a quick question.
>> He never explicitly says he promises to
preserve it. What he says though is that
the gospel, the injil, and the Torah at
the time of Muhammad are valid, reliable
as arguments for the people at the time,
the Jews Christians, to accept Muhammad
as a prophet in the same line as the
previous prophets. In other words, our
scripture in the 7th century is the
reason and the evidence that we need to
believe in Muhammad, which de facto
means it's scripture from Allah and
reliable. And and just uh six verses
after the uh verse that our friend
quoted again uh you have surah 2 verse
85 where Allah says that if the Jews
don't believe in all of their book and
they only pick and choose and believe in
parts then he will send them to hell
which that assumes that what they have
is 100% accurate. If it weren't then
they would have to just they would have
to believe in parts. and he says, "If
you only believe in parts, I'll send you
to hell." And that's just one of like 50
different reasons that he can't be he
can't be talking about a a corrupt book.
>> Now, I have nothing else to really argue
about. Uh I think you guys just stomped
at me. I just don't have anything else
cuz I just started researching
and of course
>> that's that's good by the way. That's
good researching it. Lots of people
just, you know, if if an argument is
presented, they'll just reject it and
not uh not ever bother to research it.
So, it's actually good that you're
researching it.
>> Absolutely. Like,
>> I just want to go on you go.
>> I just want I just want to add on two
two verses for your research because you
asked about where Allah says he's going
to preserve the Torah in the in that
surah. Not in that surah, but you find
elsewhere in the Quran that Allah talks
about his words being uncorrupted, that
men cannot corrupt his words. You're
going to find that in chapter 6 verse
114 115 6 114 115 and then chapter 18 27
18 27 And in those two passages you're
going to find that it's impossible for
anyone to change Allah's word. So keep
that in your
>> I'll be right back cuz I'm I think
someone's calling. I'll be right back.
>> Jabriel's calling him again. Okay, no
problem.
>> Maybe we can like uh put him in the
backstage and bring him back later or
something and have someone I don't know.
>> You can have somebody else jump in. You
can bring it back later.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh Avery, you're muted. I don't know if
you're talking to us, but we can't.
>> Who you talking to, Avery? There we go.
>> No. Yeah, I was talking to live, man. I
was trying to work out this audio, but
um Okay. Yeah. H1 is done.
>> Yeah.
>> Hey, if you want to fix your audio, um
get a time machine, go back in time, and
write a note to yourself saying, "Bring
a mic." It's powerful, powerful stuff
there.
>> I even got my wireless mics, man. That
didn't even work.
>> All right, John Fontaine, welcome.
>> Hello.
>> Hey, John. How you doing? Nice to meet
you all.
>> Nice to meet you.
>> Got the got the whole roster here. Yeah.
For the whole team.
>> I hope you guys are ready because I'm
here.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> This is your this this is your legendary
moment, JF.
>> It could be yours, but let's see.
>> So, um
>> see how it goes.
>> You know, don't count yourself out yet.
So, I'm here to basically offer David
Wood a debate, an official debate. Avery
can be the moderator. It could be on
Avery's channel. I trust Avery because
I've seen him moderate before. Um David
Wood is definitely the most
knowledgeable on this topic according to
yourself and um you as as Chris knows
and other people know I have a slightly
different take on it. So yeah I mean I
would like to maybe next Friday we can
do a official debate the does Islam
affirm the Bible with me and David. um
you know I and um also inspiring
philosophy you know I know you like to
debate you know you've been offering
some of my colleagues for debate but you
know you don't seem to ever get time so
maybe we can also debate something like
maybe is the Bible revelation according
to Islam and Christianity you know maybe
we can do that again on on channel
>> here's what I've been trying to get
Muslims to debate me though here I've
been trying to get Muslims for months to
debate me
>> no problem I'm here today I'm here today
so What we can do, we'll arrange it for
next Friday, me and David. Yeah. And
then the Friday after we can do
inspiring philosophy.
>> Well, you didn't let me say the topic on
the Bible. Is the Bible revelation
according to Islam and Christianity?
>> You didn't you didn't let me finish.
I've been trying to get Muslims for
months to debate me on the topic of
which is better for humanity,
Christianity or Islam. I've contacted at
least a dozen at this point and all of
them have backed out or of ghost to me.
Are you interested in that? because I've
been trying for a long time to get that
debate.
>> I'm I'm interested in is the Bible
revelation according to Islam and
Christianity because that's the
fundamental thing. You know, we we have
to get to the root of the cause. I mean,
it's all it's all Muslim dilemma uh you
know uh basically around all around
that. So, you know, me and David can do
does Islam affirm the Bible? me and you
can do is Bible revelation according to
Islam and Christianity. You know, we'll
pencil that in, you know, and and Chris,
you know, maybe me and you can do
something in high.
>> I can't I can't real quick. I can't do
two weeks. I'll be in Omaha. I'll be in
Nebraska in two weeks for a conference.
So, I can't do two weeks from now.
>> Okay. Maybe. When When can you do it
then? Maybe the week after.
>> Maybe. Oh, maybe. I already have an
interview scheduled that day. But,
>> but you can commit today that you will
debate me. you you will you will commit
that you will you'll debate me on is is
the Bible revelation according to Islam
and Christianity. Yeah.
>> I'd rather just debate the Islamic
dilemma with you. Like why not
just do that?
>> Me and David are going to do that and
David is the kingpin of it. So he's
going to thrash me on that. So let's
deal with
>> If you're doing the Islamic dilemma with
David, there's no point in debating on
if the Bible's revelation. That's
literally that's literally the the
Islamic dilemma debate.
>> It's the same thing.
>> No. No. Because we're going to argue
from the because the Islamic dilemma is
an internal critique arguing from an
Islamic perspective. The other one is
both Islam and Christianity. You'll
present your case, I'll present mine.
>> But you said is the is the Bible is the
Bible revelation according to the Quran,
right?
>> No, according to Islam and Christianity.
So we present both sides of that. You
get, you know, you get to defend
>> that's the Islamic dilemma.
>> Yeah, it's just the Islamic dilemma.
That's what I was saying. No, not
necessarily because you're going to
prove from a Christianity perspective as
well whether it's revelation like what
is your basis from Christianity not
arguing from the Islamic perspective
then that's a different topic if you if
you want to ask is if you want to debate
is the Bible revelation strictly from a
Christian uh paradigm I mean that's
different from an Islamic paradigm and
it doesn't make so if you do it from an
Islamic paradigm that's literally
>> let's say from the Christian paradigm
then. So is the Bible revelation
according to Christianity?
>> That's
yeah you need a whole debate on that if
the if the Bible
>> that would be like saying is the Quran
revelation according to Islam
>> according to Islam.
>> I mean I mean this is the level it
reminds me why I'm so happy I'm no
longer a Muslim because I don't have to
deal with the stupidity anymore. Is the
Quran
>> to be fair. Listen guys I've been
waiting for over an hour. You know, I've
been very
>> Yeah, but you're here just debating
about debating. You're actually Are you
planning on actually engaging with us on
a topic today?
>> Just give me one minute, guys. At least
I've been waiting, right? I'm not I'm
not just
>> I know. I'm not just a regular Muslim.
>> Isn't that crazy how I'm not just a
regular Muslim which you can pick up?
I'm the only Muslim who's wrote a book
about it.
Everybody here telling on
John. John, hold on a second, bro.
Nobody can hear you right now. Nobody
can hear you. He's probably just legend
has it he's still talking. Look.
>> So, look. Um, it was getting chaotic, so
I just had to make sure we like Avery.
He's a good moderator.
>> Thank you, man. I appreciate it. So,
>> up against each other, so get behind us.
>> They know how they know how to flow. But
you're still over talking me right now,
John.
>> So, so can we confirm Friday? What?
What? What? What? What topic does you
want? Does the Quran confirm the Bible?
>> Yeah. Yeah. No. Does Islam the Bible?
>> Does Islam
>> Islam then you're No, I'm not falling
for that one.
>> Why?
>> Because you're because Islam according
to you guys includes anything any random
commentator from a thousand years later
and so on.
>> No. No. Okay. I will not include anyone.
>> Do Quran the Bible? Do the Quran. Does
the Quran confirm the Bible?
>> Does the Quran confirm the Bible? Book.
Book. Does your book confirm my book?
>> David, let me tell you just let's call
it the Islamic dilemma.
>> Simple that you're the daddy of Islamic
dilemma. We'll debate the Islamic
dilemma. Okay?
>> You know, let's let's do the thing
Friday. Avery, I I trust you, man, cuz
I've seen you. You've been you've been
fair with all the guys. I know you'll do
a good job.
>> Um, also inspiring philosophy if he if
he uh, you know, wants to do that. And
Chris as well. You know, Chris is, you
know, in Hide Park. I find him uh uh
fairly good. But the one thing with
Chris I would ask
>> okay
>> is he has to grow a beard right because
Avery philosophy Islamic and and David
we have beards right we're following the
sun Jesus but
Jesus is
>> you know Chris is like you know at least
you have you have to get a 5:00 shadow
before the debate right you're not going
to accuse me of debating someone age
>> Chris seriously there's all this
Muhammad hijab is talking about all this
uh Arabic love poetry and how disturbing
it is because it's It talks about unless
you have a beard then they see you as a
they see you as a
>> I don't know but as I said so Chris
again you know grow I mean I'm serious
you have to grow a beard because we got
to have two ginger beards on the go
right and you don't
>> let me tell you let me tell you a with a
ginger beard
>> you would you look you you read the
Quran nearly in one sitting right and at
least you can do for your fans is grow a
beard right I'm going to be in in hide
park in November early November mber I
think the 5th around that time that that
the weekend either side of the 5th so
I'm there we can arrange something me
and you can debate did the earliest
Islamic scholars affirm the Bible cuz I
know that you said that you you've been
reading that Camila Dang and and and
Whittingham and all this stuff you're
well read on that that's your favorite
topic so we can deal with did the
earliest Islamic scholars affirm the
Bible and I'm sure you're confident in
that one aren't you? Yeah. Yeah. I can
do that,
>> man. Why don't the other Muslim
have the same spirit you do? You came,
you challenged everybody in their mama
to what we
>> and that is awesome.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Listen, listen, listen, listen. What it
is, I mean, as as it was getting a bit
uh heated before with Jay and Docing in,
people don't like to be cut off. Last
time I was on your stream, Sam cut me
off and things like that and get muted,
you know, but Avery Avery has matured a
lot. He's very fair now, more fair than
he used to be. And I've seen him. I've
seen him moderate. So I don't think the
problem with John. John, you just come
in and talk the whole time. Are you
planning on actually engaging with us on
anything tonight or you just challenging
people?
>> Yeah, it's not a bomb, man. This not the
mosque. We buy in because something
stupid is the Bible Christian.
>> I want to hear you. what we're going to
do. We me and David agreed for that.
Thank you. And and by the way, I I
to be honest, to be honest, I I don't
agree with everything David's done, but
you want to engage tonight with any
topic or you just
you've got you've got the only Muslim in
the Muslim world
J and Doc. Yeah, it's important that I'm
here.
>> We
do. You have to realize who the A team
is right here.
>> You're not important, man. Wake up. We
know who you are. Are we going to debate
David? Next Friday.
>> Are you Are you gonna Are you going to
engage with today's topic though?
>> Bro, I've been I've been for nearly two
hours.
>> It's midnight here. I've got kids to go
to bed.
>> I can't I can't debate now. And I'm not
going to debate on a platform where
you're going to cut me off and all that.
You do an official debate. Listen,
listen. You asked me a question. Let me
finish.
>> Listen, listen, listen, listen, listen.
Is that not enough for you? Are you not
entertained? Subhan Allah. I waited for
two hours, man. He's not that
entertaining.
All of you guys boring. You're boring.
>> And you want more. It's like you're
squeezing it. You're squeezing it, man.
>> You guys You guys You guys are in
America. You're nice and fresh. It's
daytime. I've had a long day. It's
midnight here.
I'm even in my sleeping. So, let me tell
you guys, I'm happy with that. David, we
can we confirm for Friday. All right.
Stop.
>> Can we Can we confirm that Avery
Avery? Let's have some order. Let's have
some order.
>> I'm fine debating the Islamic dilemma,
too.
>> Thank you. See you later.
>> No, he's going to run. Okay. Bye. Bye,
coward. Bye, Coward.
>> David, you want to debate him? I'm also
fine debating on the Islamic
>> guys. The Dawa guys when they actually
come in, they come in and they debate
about debating.
>> They don't actually debate. They come in
and they debate about debating. I mean,
respectfully, I don't know who this guy
is. This is my first time seeing this
guy. I have no idea who he is.
>> This is important. Oh, you're squeezing.
The only ones being squeezed is Muhammad
in the cave of Harat. That's the only
one being squeezed by that peg demon
debris.
>> David, if you want to debate,
>> if he wants to engage on the topic,
yeah, fine. But he just wants to debate
about debating. He just wasted all of
our time.
>> Yeah.
>> And then he goes to his Tw followers
saying, "I challenge all of them.
>> You got to you got to cut you got to cut
him some slack though. He did come here
and lay down a bunch of debate
challenges, which is the opposite of
what we're seeing from everyone except
like Daniel, right? Like so like we're
sitting there wondering why is why is
all these all the guys are saying haha
we can refute your argument. We can
refute your dumb argument. It's so dumb.
It's not even worth responding to. We're
like okay well why don't you step up and
like show us why it's a dumb argument.
And they're like no we will never do
that. And so for him to come over here
and say hey I'm ready to debate this.
Guess what? That's what they should be
doing. If they really think it's a bad
argument they can refute it. They should
be just tossing challenges
>> in every single every single direction.
So hats off to John Fontaine. for some
reason his name sounds like a like a a
doo-op singer from the ' 60s or seven
something like that. But uh anyway,
yeah. Uh sounds sound I I don't have a
lot of I have to confess I'm not good
with faces. So like for years I couldn't
tell the difference between uh
genetically modified skeptic and cosmic
skeptic even they look nothing alike but
I could not in my in my mind I could not
I still can't if you put up pictures I
could not tell the difference between
orthodox Muslim and Dean response except
for now I've identified the feature the
the duck lips. So now I could actually
tell them apart. But John Fontaine and
Hamza, like even though I've seen them
both, like if you if you if you just
showed me one of them right now, I would
not be able to tell you which one is
which. Uh but anyway, aside from all
that, um awesome, awesome, awesome to
have issuing debate challenges.
>> I I'm happy to debate him on the Islamic
dilemma as well. I just in two weeks I'm
flying to Omaha to speak at church. So I
would also relish that in any sense uh
the Islamic dilemma. So you know if you
want to throw
>> we're all ready to go.
>> Yeah. Everybody's ready to do this.
>> You could have done it.
>> And hey by by the way no also like
seriously seriously it's it's totally
good and fine to have multiple debates
on the topic with different uh with
different people because um guess what?
You know, if you go into a debate and
you're not, you know, someone brings up
a point, you're not sure how to respond
and stuff like you might figure out a
way to respond to it later and so you
want to you want it's good to it's good
to debate again. So yes, John Fontaine,
you can debate me on the topic, you can
debate IP on the topic, you can debate
Chris on the topic, you can debate Jai
on the topic, deal, we all we are all
happy to debate you over and over again
on this. Yeah. The thing is he could
have done it two hours ago. Yeah, he
could have done it now in the in the in
this 30 minute sermon that he was
getting.
>> That's actually true. He could have
debated David Chris and inspiring
philosophy on the Islamic dilemma. And
if the Bible's revelation in Islam, he
could have did that right now. That's
tough.
>> Since we know these guys are leeches and
they're clout chasers, they could have
done three ver five vers six, seven
versus one. You know, it would have been
like a title like that. But now it's
just going to be, you know, he kind of
ruined it. If he's trying to clout
chase, he's kind of ruining it.
>> So, we got uh Oh, I did want to correct
him on one thing. He was saying like he
was saying like I'm like the uh I'm like
the best on the top. That's not true.
There are other people who are better on
the top. I'm a I'm a popularizer. I'm I
will say I'm the best popularizer of the
argument. I'll say that.
>> Yeah. And is also